the homicide lieutenant with the Las
Vegas metropolitan Police Department I'm
out here this morning to brief you on a
homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 8800 block of Canyon
saddle which is a residential
neighborhood in the area of Durango and
blue diamond the details that I have
right now are very preliminary and it's
an extremely convoluted scene at this
point so I stressed that going in but
around 3:30 3:00 in the morning we
received multiple 911 calls reporting
gunshots in the area our patrol officers
arrived on scene and they observed a
black male in his mid-20s suffering from
a gunshot wound in the garage of the
residents directly behind me so what we
are being told at this point is that the
resident of the house behind me was
outside in front of his residence at
around 3:30 in the morning a car
occupied by two black males driving it's
a black BMW luck the driver of that
Mercedes exits the car and walks to the
house there is some altercation between
the resident and the driver of the
Mercedes at some point the what we're
being told is that one of the driver
pulls out a handgun which causes the
resident pull out his own handgun and
shoots the driver he is killed inside
the garage at that point the passenger
inside the mercedes-benz exits the car
and there is
the passenger in the resident at that
point the passenger ran and fled the
scene within the last hour we believe
we've captured the passenger in the
neighborhood so right now we're in the
process we've just completed our
briefing we have a lot of interviews to
do to try to piece this all together but
we do have one person detained and we
have one person deceased we are also
speaking with the person who is the
shooter for the deceased so with that I
will take a couple questions right now
it's still too early we're trying to
figure out exactly what transpired as
far as why the Sadie's the driver of the
Mercedes and the passenger were at the
residence and we're just trying to
figure out everything we're speaking
with him right now so I can't tell you
how this is gonna turn out here in the
next several hours I'm sure the story
will change somewhat right now we don't
know
don't believe I would say I don't
believe at this point it's random but
again it's still too early for me to
confirm that
so the shooting theme the deceased is
found inside the garage of the house so
he is the driver of the Mercedes Benz he
is at some point of pro you know there's
some conversation in the driveway which
leads into the garage now the exchange
of gunfire between the resident and that
person or the deceased is in the garage
however at least said we have a vehicle
down the street that has hit the with
gunfire we also have the impacts inside
of the house that was fired at from the
passenger as well so and you're trying
to simplify it the best I can but
there's that is correct there are people
inside the house who stated they did not
see the incident so we don't have any
witnesses that are coming forward to the
actual shooting
I urge anybody who has any information
to reach out to Crimestoppers you can do
it anonymously or you can also reach out
to homicide at lv MPD comm we're getting
the residence it backs up to a street
that is actually just a coal de sac so
we're letting them leave but as far as
we're gonna be out here for hours
processing this scene everybody involved
is a male in their mid twenties all
right thank you guys